all right
all right everybody can hear me all
right
so uh
i'd like to thank the organizers for
inviting me it's a great pleasure to be
here and uh i'll talk about joint work
with
talamir who was my phd student and with
ronan butzley and it will be about
sparsity
and um
i don't know if peter knows this but he
had a major non-sparse influence on my
work
uh as i started my first steps into
statistics and had mental statistics i
remember this clearly i i had some idea
about something and i talked with
david donahoe and he told me
after five minutes you should read
this paper by peter and lisa and i read
it and did it
was somewhat connected to things that i
was doing
and later on i started thinking about
covariance matrices and again
lisa and peter
were way ahead of me they had
amazing papers about covariance
regularization by thresholding but with
ian johnson and others we
still were able to do something about
sparse pca
and uh uh of course there was a paper by
sasha and the yankee and peter on
sparsity
and
actually papers by many other peoples
here but in 2010 i was here on
sabbatical with peter and we had many
many discussions on various types of
sparsity
and yeah it took me about 10 years or
more but
i'll talk about sparsity today
okay
so
uh uh the talk will be about uh
something that i think essentially maybe
everybody here has worked or or has
heard about a sparse approximation of
best subset selection
the quality setup is very simple there
is a design matrix a
there is a response vector y
uh
someone gives me a sparsity parameter k
and i would like in principle to solve
this problem i'll call this p0 okay
because i have
a requirement that i'm looking for a
vector that you exactly takes parts
uh so this folder appeals in many
different contexts one is in signal
image processing harmonic analysis
y is typically your sampling of of some
signal
a would be it's called a dictionary its
columns are are
basic signals or they're called atoms
and you want to find
how to best represent your signal by
a linear combination with most k
dictionary atoms
another application is compressed
sensing and then there you have this
pulse vector x and you observe linear
projections of it possibly with noise
and you would like to
solve the inverse problem recover
x from these
observations y
and
of course in statistics we have linear
regression of sparse linear regression
we have pairs of observations you know i
change the bit notation x y
and here
my
unknown
is a vector beta
which is
a
b
d dimensional but assumed to be sparse
and i'd like to try to predict why with
at most k variables
okay
uh in this talk i will assume that k is
known of course in pakistan it's
typically unknown
and needs to be estimated so one
possible approach
is to solve the original problem p0 for
many different values of k
and then apply close validation or some
model selection criterion or something i
will not talk about this
so in this talk i will assume that k is
given okay
and i'll focus on trying to solve this
problem p0 for a given value of k given
a given y
okay
so
the first thing to keep in mind that the
main challenge in problem in solving
this problem is is support detection
uh if someone tells them tells me
choose these columns or these variables
then
[Music]
i only need to solve for this first
problem there's no
difficulty whatsoever
unfortunately finding the optimal
support is is np hard
and yet this one is so important that
you have really extensive work
algorithms theory lower bounds upper
bounds etc
by
vast different communities from
statistics machine learning applied math
signal processing etc
uh uh
i think that just on the algorithmic
side there are at least 100 different
methods or variants of methods that try
to positively solve this problem
so what i'll try to do is
uh of course also lots of theoretical
guarantees
so try to do it in three slides okay
uh so
first let's talk about the algorithm
algorithmic side there are many methods
that are greedy you start from a
an empty supports it and you try to add
one variable at a time and this many
papers this goes back essentially to the
1960s with forward
uh stepwise linear regression
these methods most of them are very fast
very easy to program
uh but i'll show you later they they
would they may yield sub-optimal
solutions when the problem starts to
become more challenging
a different approach is which we like
very much in statistics is to replace
our non-convex
constraint by some penalty
the most
of course we have this parameter lambda
we need to tune it and if we want to a
case pulse solution we need to maybe
scan several values of lambda
and of course the most popular penalty
is the lasso which is convex so
everybody is happy
and we also have various recovery
guarantees for it under those conditions
like incoherence obviously there is
etcetera etcetera it's also by now
they're very very fast methods to solve
a the subpoena even very large scale and
yet uh uh
joey and bryan it may yield highly
suboptimal solutions
uh
okay now in the last maybe eight years
uh
i'm aware
there was a very interesting work
by people at mit
uh this paper for example uh
they
proposed a mix into the programming
approach that
when it ends it found the globally
optimal solution okay and you read the
paper it's very convincing
uh
it solves it globally
and
at least if you look at the examples in
their paper they're able to to solve
problems let's say with 100 variables or
so much faster than exhaustive search
but
it could be very slow for example we
took their code
and on a very small relatively small
matrix
we ran this on a huge cluster and it
took us several days okay i'm talking
about 30 observations 180 variables
this
they significantly speeded up this
approach there's a new paper uh with the
cutting playing method and this method
is able to solve things much louder in
you know let's say 10 minutes run time
and yet another
recent approach is is also by role model
from mit he he proposed some
a calling a descent with a small local
combinatorial cell this is a greedy
approach
there is no a certificate of optimality
but at least
his code can can handle you know a
million variables in in less than a
minute and
uh
i would say you know it's a relatively
recent paper with relatively
excellent performance
uh on the theoretical side we have many
many guarantees i'm not going to list
all of them
under central conditions many different
people some of them are hearing the
audience have proved that current
methods are either optimal if there's no
noise or rate optimal
and
uh so you could ask yourself has the
problem been solved
uh it has not been solved yet should
should someone work on it and
my
point i'll try to convince you is that
there's still
some work to be done
and again the key limitation just from
the practical point of view is that
uh
as the problem becomes more difficult
let's say as as
you start to have higher values of k
okay larger k is less sparse the
opponent becomes more difficult
uh
either all of the muscles that i've
reviewed either they
will find solutions
from optic from optimal or may take
essentially
forever to run okay so let me
understand
well so
there are two ways one is when there is
no noise and your vector is exactly k
sparse you want the er so they'll
understand the conditions solving a
basis pursuit recovers the ldl spouse's
solution
on the statistical side you you add
noise and and you ask what is the
uh
the
you add the statistical model and then
you ask them
no
i'll talk about something slightly
different because i'm going to have a
noise that is
not random just
[Music]
i'm not going to have
a random noise okay
all right but just to illustrate the
empirical performance of various methods
this is a very simple simulation your
matrix is 100 by 800.
run gaussian matrix
uh
i'm
making the volume harder and harder okay
i i generate a case path vector x
add noise to it
and try to run various different
algorithms and first i'm just asking on
the optimization side not even about
accuracy of recovery or anything else
did i get a solution whose residual is
is
is smaller or comparable to that of the
original x0 okay if i if if this ratio
is close to one or even smaller than one
then my x hat may possibly be
an accurate estimate of x and if this
ratio is much larger than one then
probably i you know i if just on the
optimization side i was not able to find
a good solution okay
all right so this is the result for the
lasso
or basis pursuit so
the x-axis is the sparsity as you can
see
for this specific example the lasso
essentially works only for positive
levels less than 16 or so okay because
it starts to go higher and higher
these two are
eternity weightedly squares literally
wait at l1 what
yes we'll discuss this lower in a minute
okay but
let's focus on on this region for a
minute okay
this is iterative support detection
and what i want to show you is
our method which does this
uh
to anticipate your question in this
region there is overfitting okay there
is now the fact that you find a solution
with a
a
this ratio smaller than one does not
mean that you were able to find the
correct support okay
but the focus would be on this region
okay
uh so in just to to to illustrate your
point i'm going to take this k equals 36
this is the average of many many many
runs so i'm going to show you uh uh
you know let's say the 100 other
specific realization so what i'm showing
you here is for explosive 36
uh
this
now i'm really showing you the
construction error both of our method
and and of iterative support detection
over maybe 100 different realizations
a
when this ratio is much smaller than one
so
the points that are here
both methods succeeded
all of these points are realizations
where our method succeeded and utility
support detection didn't and these are
cases where both methods fail to
succeed okay so
um all right
okay so that was a motivation and now
let's talk about
so our our goal is to solve p0 but i
want to
do it by a panelization approach okay so
what would
be good properties for a penalty
function
well first of all if someone gives me
the value of k the target's positive i
may want my penalty to depend explicitly
on this target's positive level that i
wish to achieve
in terms of my penalty parameter lambda
i would like that
when i solve this problem and i take
very large lambda i would like the
solution to be close to those of the
original p0 and better yet maybe i would
like them to coincide for sufficiently
large lambda
and
the third opening which is important
otherwise i will not be giving this talk
i would like
whatever penalty i suggest to be somehow
easy easy with double quotations to
optimize otherwise i didn't do much okay
so first let me discuss a penalty that
satisfies the first two points depends
on k
and
its solutions are close to the p0
this penalty
is called the oh i'll call it the trim
lasso
we came up with it but later we find out
that
small people came up with this penalty
before us
uh so
you just take
like the lasso but you just
don't penalize the top k coefficients
you just penalize the l1 norm of the
tail okay so it's essentially it
measures the distance of your vector to
the nearest case pulse vector okay if
your vector is k is plus the penalty is
zero okay
so
this penalty appeared in paypal by
people from approximation theory and
people in signal processing
and
also in people from optimization and
also in the work by uh the people from
mit
and they actually coined uh at least as
far as i know that
they coined the name trimble
okay
um
so this is the the
penalty that we're going to look at
and you can ask various questions first
of all if you add a penalty of this form
rather than the lasso what is the
relation to the original problem p0
uh what values of the penalty parameter
lambda should you use
uh
can you how well can you recover a
vector x if you're using this penalty
and on the particle side how can you
optimize an objective when you have such
a penalty now keep in mind this penalty
is how to opt it's non-convex and it's
how to optimize if you have a vector
which has k large coefficient and the
other one is small
your penalties is the l1 norm of the
ones that are small but if you make a
small perturbation and
you know you switch the roles
of the case and came k plus one or k
minus one because become largest the the
the penalty is highly known smooth
as as as you perturb x
okay so what i'm going to show
in this talk is
uh
i'll try to address essentially
questions one two three
uh i'll try to convince you that
actually you should solve if you're
interested in small solutions you should
actually solve problems with the
trimble
but
that is typically difficult to optimize
and you should actually use a
a surrogate penalty
that
is much easier to optimize
okay
all right
um so here is a so the original problem
is p0 i'll call this poland p lambda
with the stream that's so penalty
and the first question we'll ask is how
to choose lambda
and here's a very simple lemma that we
pulled that
if you have your design matrix a you
compute what is the largest norm of of
your of your atoms of your columns
and
if you take any penalty that is larger
than a
the norm of y times this uh largest norm
of of any column then any
local minimum of p lambda is k-sparse
okay
and uh
what this means is that
for large enough lambda
the optimal solutions of p lambda
coincide with those of p zero okay so
you could instead solve b lambda
uh
of course this would also be np-half yes
there's no free lunch
yet
it will be maybe
later
okay
but
in terms of a strategy you can think
about trying to solve a the problem with
any a set of increasing values of lambda
until you get to a case pulse solution
and this is going to happen certainly
once lambda surpasses
that threshold
okay
now
a a little bit about a relatively simple
a single recovery guarantee that we're
able to derive and this will be related
to your question about optimality you
see i i don't
my model is that i observe a vector y
which is ax 0 plus e
x 0 is a unknown this is what i want to
recover and e is not random just
measurement 0
and what i'm going to assume that x 0 is
approximately case pulse so
approximately means this that
its distance to the nearest case pulse
vector is much much smaller than its
l1 norm and i'm going to assume that the
norm of e is small okay
and the question is well my problem of
course is to recover x0
given a y and k and the question is can
i do it
by solving p lambda
yeah
we will see immediately what what it
means to be small okay but
all right
now
this problem
is of course imposed because i didn't
yet say anything about the matrix a
so for example a
even in the absence of noise and and
with the super computer to be able to
recover my x0 i need or any x0 i need
any two k columns of of a to be linearly
independent
and what i'm going to assume for my
analysis is is something similar to a
restricted geometry property i'm going
to assume that
this
requirement so it's like an lip
it's one sided i don't care about the
other side and i
it's with mixed nose because
that's
maybe some some of our limitations but
this coefficient alpha 2k i only need it
to be larger than zero but
i don't need it to be bounded away from
zero so this is the assumption i'm going
to make
and
two small things before i describe the
result
one is that notation if you give me a
vector of x i'll defined by pi k of x is
projection into the nearest case path
vector okay
all right so now i want to describe some
recovery guarantee with the streamless
penalty
and
so
i'm solving an unconvex problem
so
what i'm going to assume is something
maybe non-standard i'm going to assume
that whatever algorithm you employed
was able to find a reasonably good
solution so what is a reasonably good
solution
i'm assuming that we found a solution
whose objective
is smaller than that of the projection
of the original x0
okay so
pi k of x0 is a feasible solution it's
case powers and i want to find the
i would say that my optimization
algorithm succeeded if people find the
vector x hat whose objective is smaller
than this so what i'm going to show you
is that if this
occurred i cannot guarantee it will
occur i'm solving an unconvex problem
but if this occurred then x hat or its
projection i'll close to x zero okay
and this is the okay so
and this is the result this is the
result if x hat is not case path but
let's take it the
let's look at this formula it's a bit
simpler
if x hat itself was k sparse
then i have a bound on its l1 norm and
it involves two terms one is
how a
a non-sparse
non-cancer spouse was x0 if x0 was case
plus then
this first term would be 0.
and the other term
involves the errol the norm of e and
also how much
x0 was non-spouse and of course it's
exploded by one over alpha 2k okay so
this is exactly where how small can can
the measurement l be
two important things about this result
it holds for
any alpha i don't and alpha can be
absolutely close to zero
uh
and
i don't need it to be bounded away from
there
okay
so um
ah okay yeah this is if x hat was was k
spouse
if x hat is not case files there is a
more
involved formula which also depends on
your penalty parameter lambda
and the important
take-home lesson from this formula is
that
in fact i don't necessarily need to
solve the problem p lambda with a very
large lambda i may solve it with a
lambda smaller than
a lambda where i get a k-spot solution i
may still
get a solution
whose projection is close to my x zero
so
i can solve i can try to solve my my my
objective with the lambda for which
this optimal solution doesn't
necessarily coincide with p0 and
smaller lambda hopefully is somewhat
easier
for them to optimize
okay and again the recovery is stable
with respect to measurement l and in
exactly some sparsity
uh
in comparison to the lasso
all guarantees
are worse they have a worse dependence
on on the inexplicity of
of the x0 but
they don't require the lip constant to
be strictly bounded away from zero
we only require it to be just positive
which is a necessary condition for
uniform successfully recovered by any
algorithm whatsoever
okay so
before i move to the a
computational part i hope that i've
convinced you that maybe trying to
optimize things
with a return plus law is a promising
approach
the question now is how to do it
okay so this is our objective
and uh these two papers they both also
consider this objective and they try to
they both propose different methods to
optimize it
both lessons don't work so well at least
not on challenging problems and again
the reason is that this penalty is
highly non-smooth you change you take a
vector you know whose coefficients are
slowly decaying you perturb it a bit the
the top k coefficients change
by a lot
and many of these methods get stuck at
some local minima
at the incorrect support okay let me
show you some results so this is
comparison to dc programming this
programming was a method
proposed in this paper
so i'm showing you results for different
velocity levels when the sparse is small
k equals 15 this is an easy problem yes
on the previous slide i mean i'm just
extrapolating from the title
is it just to write tau k as the l one
more minus the sum of the largest k term
and yes and then
it's a difference between two convex
functions and they are good heuristics
for this
not so good
not so good but maybe in this case it's
not so good but in general
there's some good heuristics
we took their code or we re-implemented
it i'll show you a totally different
approach okay
okay because you see like a good
heuristic is to linearize the second one
so it becomes a fine
yeah i don't even know by heart what
exactly they did let me show you what we
did and
okay but
immediately when k is small it's an easy
problem
uh what i'm showing you here is the uh
whether the optimization succeeded okay
whether you find
a solution which is feasible and has a
lower objective than the true solution
then and if it's on a logarithmic scale
so anything here is success anything
here is failure and all of these are
instances where our method succeeded and
dcp failed
the story with adm is similar
when k small it succeeds when case has
to be large it fails okay
all right so now we come to
the last part of my talk
which is
how to
practically optimize
this penalty
and for that
um
i'll rewrite it in a different way okay
so
this is the definition of the trim the
sole
but instead i'm going to write it as
follows
thank you a vector of length d
go over choose any possible subset of
size
k or size b minus k let's say size d
minus k and sum up its corresponding
coefficients
and take the one
whose
sum is smallest okay
all right
so
this just tells you that the triangular
saw can be viewed as a hard minimum
namely you go over all possible subsets
and you choose the one with the minimal
l1 norm
and
our idea is to we're going to replace
this halt minimum
by soft minimum this is what people in
neural networks do all the time
so this will be our surrogate okay
so
you start on your vector x
this is right now it's a thought
experiment we're going to
expand it to a vector z
of length exponential in x whose
coordinates will be
for any subset omega its coordinates
will be
the sum of the corresponding
uh
the trimble so is the minimum of this
vector and we're going to replace this
minimum by soft mean
okay
so this is what exactly what people do
in in in in neural networks it's the
last layer it's a softmax
formula used in multi-class
classification
so
here's the soft max of uh from m
categories
we need the soft means we're going to
add a minus
uh we're going to add the smoothness
parameter gamma
and we're going to average
the thing inside doesn't matter just
adds a constant
and
we're going to plug in the original
definition of the
huge vector z
and
this is our
surrogate penalty okay we call it the
general soft min
yes so what so we are going to replace
tau
the trimble by this penalty
and uh
let's look a bit what are these properly
so first of all
it's infinitely differentiable in terms
of absolute value of x
that's good we'll be able to maybe do
stuff with gradients and such
the parameter a gamma controls this
level of smoothness we'll show in a
minute it has nice properties when gamma
goes to zero gamma goes to infinity
and you can also think about the
formulation perspective
if your target x0 is k sparse but you
don't know
but you have a uniform prior over all
possible subsets where it's k sparse
you could think about this as your
version prior and add it as a
you know
and i'll i'll show you in a minute that
it is
somewhat or significantly easier to
optimize
okay so
some properties about this function it's
one of them decreasing
as you increase gamma
and this has a nice opposite if you take
gamma to zero
you get the lasso up to a multiplicative
factor and when you take gamma to
infinity you get the trim blossom okay
so it actually you can somehow
interpolate between the convex lasso and
and the penalty that is much closer to
the linear pawn p0 that you wanted to
solve
and
and
as i said instead of optimizing this we
suggest to optimize a sequence of
functions
with this generalized soft mean
where
we propose a hematopoie a hematopoies
scheme we start from a very small gamma
zero let's say even zero for zero you
start from the convex l1 problem and you
start to increase gamma and you track
your solution okay you you initialize
your your new object you try to
optimize your object your new objective
starting from the previous solution for
a slightly smaller gamma
[Music]
okay
all right now
still
as appealing as it this may seem there
is a problem
uh
because this objective is non-convex as
well
and
uh the way we're gonna approach it is
again standard in optimization we're
going to use module modulation
minimization we're going to construct a
different function
that majorizes
this penalty we're going to do a first
order taylor expansion and this is the
definition of a majorized function it's
a function of two variables
uh and it coincides with the original
penalty
when the two variables are the same
so if you do majority minimization
you're guaranteed to decrease
monotonically typically only to a
stationary point
uh
i'm not going to go into the details i'm
going to tell you and so
these are some ways that are related to
the gradient of my
penalty
the key point is that
this you do the first taylor expansion
you get this as your majorizer
and what's important about this
majorizer is that you know you have two
two variables x and x tilde
uh so this
majorizer
some of these terms are constant with
respect to x
and therefore
doing a majority of minimization step
you only need to solve
a convex
weighted l1 problem so that you can just
plug in into any classic standard solver
that is out there
solve this
do several majority minimization steps
and i'm done
okay so this is essentially similar to
relatively iteratively weighted l1
there's an important difference that
although all my weights are bounded
between zero and one they have
the same sum so you don't need how much
time
two minutes okay i started two minutes
late three minutes
i only have
15 slides to go
okay
so i don't need to a
a regularized which is crucial in it of
the weighted l1
okay the last
technical thing
all of this would not be useful if i
didn't have a way to compute these terms
these terms involve an exponential
number of terms
so if you think about it a little bit so
the calculation is out of the question
if you think a little bit
you will be able to come up with the
recursive formula to compute these
quantities it will be highly unstable
because you're computing x of gamma
times something and gamma is going to be
large so we need to be very very careful
i'm not going to go into the details we
developed a scheme that
takes all the kd operations to compute
the various required quantities so it's
not the bottleneck the bottleneck is is
solving the l1 problems okay
and um let me show you some results
let's keep everything else
uh
okay i'll show you some results
this is a similar simulation to to the
one in hazim and mazumder which in turn
i think is also similar to the
simulation that
peter bulman had in one of his papers so
you have a
spell signal
the design matrix is correlated
i generate a vector y it has noise
and i have various measures of success
so this is the coordinate descent method
of mazondel this is when i add
is local combinatorial search
and this is our method so we're able to
recover the correct support with roughly
20 percent
fewer observations which at least in
some compressed sensing applications
could be
important
this is for a relatively high snl if i
have a lower snl the same picture just
you need more samples to recover the
correct support will just be able to do
it with your observations
uh i'll stop
here before yankee stops me himself
okay so to conclude
uh
as we all know the
sparsity plays a key role in many many
applications i think that on challenging
instances there is still room for
improvement
i think that the timbre saw is a
desirable
approach
uh and uh i think the approach i
described may be useful in other
problems involving a combinatorial
search and sparsity
there is code there's a paper thank you
very much
if there is a really burning question
are you happy to hear it oh and was to
answer it
thank you very much for nice talking
thank you very much for your nice talk
um so my question is
um i like uh is there any like solid
theoretical evidence on like this trim
lasso is better than lasso say could you
give us some setups where like let's say
i can have a like infinitely powerful
optimizer that just solves the trim
lasso and lasso
just so statistically
um is there any case where trim lasso is
absolutely better in terms of say mse or
recovery
are you assuming that your a that you
have an old quality is able to minimize
the trim the sole yes yes i assume such
alcohol so for example there is that
you know the the recovery guarantee that
i showed you holds for any
alpha larger than zero and for the lasso
you know that their dictionaries
[Music]
with alpha small for which the lasso
will probably fail but how b can be your
error
because the alpha
is in the numerator but you have the
error norm in the numerator right so is
what is the snl that you can work with
uh
the ratio between the ax and yeah yeah
so it depends on how
practically
i i
i i didn't work with i did simulation
similar to what previous people designed
and i
this is what i i didn't play with
actual data
theoretical results are not about
selection but about the theoretical
result is is assuming k is known
no i mean that they're bound to the l1
error yes yes and this is not a
selection type result this is estimation
result correct yeah yeah yeah okay yeah
it's an estimation
to your question i have an answer in one
case it is minimax optimum if if matrix
is identity matrix then one can prove
that this solution is exactly minimum
there's a very famous like statistics
science paper comparing best obsessed
selection and lasso and also
other lots of approaches basically the
message is that if the signal noise
ratio is high then best the substance
solution is better but on the other end
like if the signal is weak then lasso
can be better it can be better so you're
talking about the paper by tip
right right right right
the review paper i i i i have some
criticisms about the paper but i'm not
going to tell them now but i can discuss
it
i'm happy to discuss thank you
any other questions
no and that's not the question i know
it's an answer let's let's like thank
both um and overspeakers
i just have a a couple of housekeeping
announcements so um we have a reception
and poster session starting um
at five just outside you can probably
see the poster boards
there is food there
dinner is tomorrow and
if you registered for the dinner you
should have received an email from judy
macdonald confirming it if you haven't
received such an email then you probably
didn't register
if you can't remember whether you
registered or not
you can send me an email tonight
we had a few last minute cancellations
so i do have a few
open spaces for the dinner so if you
didn't register but you changed your
mind and you want to go you can also
send me an email tonight about that but
please don't do it tomorrow so tonight
only um and um i'll i will see everybody
tomorrow at nine o'clock thanks
you